hey everyone bandit here to continue my
series of explaining the lore and
backstories of the various characters
introduced to us in elden ring i have
chosen ronnie the witch as my next story
fleshing out victim which i will explain
once again in a way that anyone can
understand however before we tackle
ronnie since going live with the last
video covering america i was chatting
with my good buddy monster maze who you
guys should totally check out because
he's about to go live with some elden
ring content and we were just you know
swapping stories talking about bosses
contemplating lore and he brought to my
attention several pieces of actual
in-game dialogue from america that i
completely missed because they didn't
show up for me and i still can't get
them to show up but thankfully someone
uploaded a text dump of every piece of
dialogue in the game so as long as i
know keywords of what i'm searching for
i've got all the references i need and
i'll link to this text dump in the
description below if anyone else is
interested in text dumpster diving
anyway i wanted to quickly cover these
new quotes as a sort of addendum to my
merica explained video before going on
to ronnie and if you're not interested
in hearing some extra juicy tidbits of
lore about the eternal queen then no
worries just skip ahead to the timestamp
displayed on screen and once again there
are spoilers in this video about many
things you've been warned apparently
when you're resting at the grey spots in
some churches and other areas across the
lands between there's a chance or some
sort of trigger that i haven't figured
out yet that will result in melana just
manifesting out of thin air like she do
and offering to dictate to you america's
words that she apparently said to
various individuals in a time past when
you rest at the third church of america
for instance melania pops up and says
this the words of queen america who
vanished long ago if you wish i will
share them with you very well in
america's own words my lord and thy
warriors i divest each of thee of thy
grace with thine eyes dimmed you will be
driven from the lands between you will
wage war in a land afar where you will
live and die when you go to the church
of pilgrimage she continues by saying
this then after thy death i will give
back what i once claimed return to the
lands between wage war and brandish the
elden ring grow strong in the face of
death warriors of my lord lord godfrey
she continues elsewhere by saying i
declare mine intent to search the depths
of the golden order through
understanding of the proper way our
faith our grace is increased those
blissful early days of blind belief are
long past my comrades why must he falter
and finally once more by saying hark
brave warriors hark my lord godfre we
commend your deeds guidance hath
delivered ye through each ordeal to the
place ye stand put the giants to the
sword and confine the flame atop the
mount let a new epoch begin an epoch
glistening with life brandished the
elden ring for the age of the earth tree
from these quotes to me it sounds most
like merica was speaking to lord godfrey
obviously and his warriors before they
assaulted the fire giants like i was
talking about in my last video but the
most interesting takeaway to me is the
fact that merica told them that they
would become tarnished and would be
stripped of grace and then resurrected
it proves that the desperation of the
greater will in administering grace to
the tarnished which includes you the
player was always a part of america's
plan pretty good proof for the fact that
merica was not super content with the
greater will itself but i'm still
convinced that merica is no boy scout
because even though i mentioned gideon's
fear at glimpsing into the will of
america last time i didn't mention what
he says to you after you kill him he
says that a tarnished cannot become a
lord not even you and he said this after
glimpsing into the will of queen america
meaning that even though america created
the tarnish to one day return and help
her out with the whole rebellion against
the greater will it isn't going to end
well for you who would be the elden lord
gideon knew it and tried to stop us
because whatever america had planned
after the elden beast was removed from
her body made him shudder from fear
there are a few other quotes from
america but they don't necessarily
deepen the lore so i'll leave those up
to you to hopefully stumble across in
the game if you're more lucky than i am
but the last one i'll mention is a very
peculiar quote indeed she talks directly
to ratagon and says oh ratagon leel
hound of the golden order vowed yet to
become me thou art yet to become a god
let us be shattered both mine other self
okay not only is this huge because it is
the only time to my knowledge in the
entire game where we can actually see at
least part of a conversation between
ratigan and america but it also seems to
imply that the shattering was something
they both agreed upon doing no doubt to
be followed by ratican's reforging if
you remember in the last video i said
that i believed ratagon was literally a
great rune and by the way that
crisscross pattern that i had a hunch
was a great rune is proven to be a great
rune by the description of ratagan's
scar seal and sorceal talismans thank
you very much zen f pal for your comment
and combining that notion with america's
quote and the original trailer for the
game we are left with the fuller picture
of merica telling ratigan that they both
need to be shattered and re-forged back
together because ratagan was yet to
become her meaning the plan was for him
to become her i still believe that
ratigan was created from america
initially since she calls him her other
self before ratigan becomes her meaning
this was a reunion if you will and
america probably needed ratigan to enter
her body once again because she knew the
greater will would imprison her and
prevent her from moving but radagon
would still be able to take over the
body and carry out her will should the
tarnished fail to enter the earth tree
and destroy the elden beast controlling
merica from within which was more than
likely her ultimate plan to use the
tarnished in order to free herself of
the elden beast and control of the
greater will however ratigan once inside
america's body being the quote leel
hound of the golden order decided that
the elden beast needed to remain right
where it was and rebelled against
america's wishes by trying to stop the
tarnish by closing off the tree from
entry and even attempting to stop you
himself once you burn the tree and enter
anyway finally giving us an explanation
and closure to not only ratigan's
hostility but also america's plan in its
entirety another interesting smaller
america detail is that the smith hughes
who appears to be of the misbegotten
race who are usually imprisoned or
forced into slavery located in the
roundtable hold is implied to be
imprisoned there by queen america since
he can be heard praying to her asking
for mercy it seems that he was tasked by
america to aid the tarnished warriors
and either create a weapon powerful
enough to or help the tarnish become
capable of killing a god most likely the
greater will which is something that the
people of nocron also tried to do in
order to kill the greater will and were
subsequently wiped out over but more on
that in a bit just a little more proof
that america was actively working
against the greater will and as you can
tell these america quotes and other
pieces of lore were kind of a big deal
but there weren't too many of them which
is why i decided to talk about them here
because there wasn't quite enough to
make another entire video for but now
that we're well over 1 000 words into
what is supposed to be ronnie's video
let's actually start talking about
ronnie in the first place and this is
something i didn't do last time i think
that in order to talk about ronnie we
first need to establish an understanding
of what exactly an empirian is since
ronnie claims that both she and the
twins mikola and millennia are emperians
yet we never get a straight answer as to
what makes an empirian and emperian and
now i've said empyrean too many times
and it doesn't sound real anymore anyway
most fans of elden ringlorn know by now
that the claimed explanation for what
makes an empirian comes from the item
description of the remembrance of the
rot goddess which the player obtains
upon killing millennia it says quote
mikala and millenia are both the
children of a single god as such they
are both emperians but suffered
afflictions from birth this was quickly
accepted as meaning that those born of a
single god are emperian which does seem
to be what the quote is implying
directly however it's also become more
and more debated as people claim that
the quote is instead simply saying that
being born of a single god means they
were inbred and therefore is the
reasoning behind their afflictions i do
think that if you take this quote by
itself and nothing else into account
this is bound to be eternally debatable
but allow me to provide my personal take
on the matter i think that the quote has
to be pointing to the single god origin
for emperians for two reasons one
because of the way this description was
written it literally says that they're
born of a single god and as such they
are imperians that as such part there is
another way of saying because of this or
therefore and is meant to relate the
idea that's coming next with the idea
that came before for instance i could
say my vehicle was made by honda as such
it is a car but has i don't know what
stinky interior or something the phrase
immediately following that as such is
what relates to the first statement
directly in this case imperian equals
from a single god like car equals made
by honda in my amazing example the
affliction suffered from birth part is
just another fact being brought up about
the imperium twins just like the stinky
interior is simply a fact brought up
about my honda car send air fresheners
the second reason i think the single god
theory is true is because of the inverse
that is the fact that only michaela
millennia and ronnie are emperians
according to ronnie none of the other
demigods are imperian who are also all
the children of america or ratigan aka
the god in this very statement and what
is the only difference between the
imperial demigods and the others yup it
is conveniently that mykola and millenia
were born of ratigan and america one god
combine all these trains of thought
together and even though it is still
admittedly debatable and it is possible
that being an emperian simply means just
being chosen of the greater will i just
happen to think it's a bit more
believable that empirians must have come
from a single god and that there has to
be a literal requirement because i can't
think of any reasons why some of the
others like the super loyal to the
golden order general radon for instance
would not be a chosen empirian in that
case but i hear you wondering bandit
what about ronnie isn't she the child of
ranala and ratigan which according to
your own words would make her not an
emperian what a wonderful question and
perfect segway into finally talking
about ronnie's story properly it all
begins with an egg this egg remember how
last time i was talking about ratigan
falling in love with ranala and the two
of them marrying and making little
red-haired babies together and then how
ratigan broke granola's heart when he
left her to return to america and make
babies with his other self instead well
upon leaving the queen of the full moon
ratigan randomly gifted her with an egg
or was it random see it's a big mystery
as to why he would give her an egg of
all things but fortunately we can read
item descriptions and speak to sir
gideon off near the all-knowing for some
more information according to gideon
turns out that radigan's gift to ranala
is a great rune inside the egg the great
rune of the unborn to be exact the
description of the rune itself also
reconfirms this and it also tells us
that that unborn part of the rune is
referring to unborn demigods and tells
us that the egg itself is actually made
of amber which comes from the sap of the
urgery and has primordial life inside
now this next section is going to be
kind of theoretical but bear with me
it's going to make sense i promise if
ronnie is an emperian and emperians have
to originate from a single god then i
believe that ronnie actually came from
the rune of the unborn demigods or maybe
it would be better to say it came from
her see ronnie calls ranala her mother
and the giant smith eg confirms that
ronnie grew up at the carrier manor so
she's probably not a child of america
and ratigan but as we can see on her
dead corpse which i will explain later
in the video even though the corpse is
charred we can tell that ronnie had red
hair when she was a physical being red
hair is obviously a direct connection to
radigan's lineage gideon also tells us
that ronnie once had a great rune
herself but that she cast it aside which
is huge because that rune has to be
accounted for and it just so happens
that her mother who is not herself a
demigod is in possession of a great rune
gifted to her by ratigan so perhaps the
entire point behind the great rune of
the unborn is that it was ronnie
radigan's last gift to rinala a demi-god
child that he created and when certain
events transpired which we will get to
in just a bit ronnie cast aside her
physical body ratigan's created child
was undone unborn also casting aside her
great rune which her mother found out
about and was driven to insanity over
losing her perfect child and last
remembrance of ratigan placing ronnie's
great rune inside an amber egg forever
trying to use the amber as magic to
rebirth her precious daughter ronnie but
forever creating imperfect clones now of
course this is unfortunately still
theoretical and has not yet been
confirmed by anything in game but it is
the most believable origin story for
ronnie that ties everything i've talked
about together so far so for now this is
what i'm going with moving on once
ronnie was given to ranala who became
her adoptive mother ratigan left to
return to america's side which according
to several sources left rinala
absolutely heartbroken and completely
beside herself which led the other
members of the academy to realize that
she deep down does not possess the real
qualities of a champion present-day
rinalda is a mind-broken individual who
was obsessed with birthing imperfect
children from the rune inside the amber
egg over and over again calling them her
sweeties even offering to make you one
of her sweeties potentially even
creating said sweeties from dead people
since she asks if her sweeties have left
to become gravestones to be better born
anew possibly in reference to her dead
daughter ronnie but even though
present-day ronaldo is a crazy sweetie
lady who really misses her family this
does not change the fact that she was
ronnie's mother when ronnie still walked
to the earth as one of the living and
her influence on ronnie because she
raised her is quite apparent since
ronnie did not grow up in lane del to
believe in the golden order but rather
grew up and carry a manner with a keen
interest in the order of the stars which
is proof of influence from her mother
and one other person you can also find
what is most likely renault's talisman
on ronnie's corpse and when fighting
ranala a deadly spell that ronnie left
to protect her mother takes over and a
fabricated ranala fights you in the real
ronald's stead and after defeating the
spell ranala says oh little ronnie my
dear daughter weave thy night into being
further proving to us that the two were
close and again painting the picture
that ronnie was in fact raised by her
mother not her father it also makes
sense from an emotional standpoint that
ronnie would grow up to despise the
golden order because that was the very
reason her father abandoned her mother
and ronnie herself and subsequently
broke ranala's heart and mind before
ronnie was very old she was recognized
as an imperian by her own two fingers
and given a shadow blithe which as i
mentioned in the last video is one of
the requirements to become the vessel of
the elden ring eg mentions that the two
of them grew up together and that blyth
was accepted into the family by ronald
to be ronnie's stepbrother which
inevitably led to their becoming very
close one day when ronnie was a bit
older she was playing in the woods and
came across a mysterious individual
known as the snow witch who became
ronnie's secret mentor and taught her
cold sorceries and to fear the dark moon
the doll and clothing that we now know
ronnie to possess was actually modeled
after the snow witch not ronnie's
physical body it was around this time
that ronnie decided she didn't want the
fate that the two fingers were trying to
force upon her she did not want to be
quote controlled by that thing that
thing most likely being a reference to
what would happen if she were to succeed
queen america a reference to the elden
beast currently residing inside queen
america and which even merica herself
extravagantly plotted against when she
explained her plight to her best friends
eg the giant and blythe her brother they
both were completely willing to forsake
the greater will and instead follow her
blythe was even said to be willing to
defy destiny itself if it would ever
have him betray ronnie and after her new
ventures into cold magic he donned a
cape because he was cold which is
adorable at some point ronnie's defiance
of the golden order led her to research
how to get rid of the golden order and
her research either from the snow witch
or studyings of the academy yielded her
with a complex solution to the entire
problem and the first step of that
solution was that she had to die
physically in order to shed herself of
her imperian body but she could not be
killed by normal means which is why she
stole the rune of death from malaketh
also known as destined death in order to
take her own life and create the black
knives which are the weapons used by the
assassins on the night of the black
knives as the demi-gods began to fall
but things get a little complicated when
the actual plan goes down and ronnie
steals the rune of death and gets killed
but then so does godwin america's first
born favorite son at the exact same time
in fact which led to only half of the
completed curse mark of death being
carved into ronnie's flesh with the
other half being carved into godwins
this is confusing but my prevailing
theory is as follows what if using
destined death to kill somebody means
having the curse mark carved into their
body period and what if having that
curse mark carved into your flesh means
that you will be eliminated wholly from
reality as in both in spirit and in
flesh but what if ronnie figured out
that you can cheat the system if you
interrupt the mark halfway so that it
would only kill one element of your
being or the other but not both since
her conscious spirit still needed to be
kept alive and she needed her physical
body to die what if she had to choose
someone else's spirit to be killed in
her stead and it also had to be the
spirit of a demigod like herself cue the
assassination of godwin the golden a
demigod who had his spirit taken from
him with half of the curse mark of death
carved on his body so that ronnie's
could live on also by the way the black
knife assassins themselves who carried
out ronnie's mission of assassinating
godwin the golden are actually all women
from the land of newman the same land
where queen america came from with quote
close ties to america herself i'll be
honest with you i'm not sure what to
make of that at this present point in
time but i just wanted to throw it out
there for your information to do with
what you will i may return to explaining
them at some point in the future if you
guys want but anyway back to ronnie with
her plan successfully carried out and
her body killed with her spirit
lingering she was then bound to a doll
that was made to resemble her tutor the
snow witch which is the body that she
uses functionally to this day as proven
to us in one of the game trailers the
murder of godwin triggered the war known
as the shattering after which the
greater will extended its grace to the
tarnish and the events of the game begin
at this point ronnie's story can
actually be expounded upon in-game
through her questline which is something
i will do now ronnie actually appears
before the tarnished pretty quickly
although she hides her true name and
instead calls herself rena for some
reason maybe in a reference to her
mother renala but either way she appears
and claims that torrent your trusty
steed's former owner entrusted her with
a gift for you since you now own torrent
she gives you the spirit calling bell
and then says she doubts the two of you
will ever meet again and wonders aloud
how long you will trust the word of the
two fingers before vanishing away into
thin air now because of her one closed
eye her vanishing in and out of thin air
and her relation to torrent or at least
torrance former master there is a theory
out there that ronnie is melana your
fingermaiden who is apparently torrance
former owner and gave you torrance
calling whistle but one thing that's
weird with this theory is the fact that
melania could have just given you the
spirit calling bell at any point herself
just like she gave you tauren's whistle
so it's unexplainable why she would have
chosen to have ronnie i mean rena
randomly give it to you instead but
talking about that theory is big enough
for another video on its own so i
digress the next time you meet ronnie is
after making your way through the
carrier manor you know the one that's
full of those finger spiders
beyond the manor is an area called the
three sisters with three towers located
within one called rena's rise one called
selvius's rise and the last called
ronnie's rise understandably ronnie is
waiting for you in ronnie's rise when
you talk to her she says she doesn't
remember giving you an invitation but
since you're just so darn interesting
you might be interested in swearing
loyalty to her purpose in helping her
out obviously you say yes and at this
point she tells you to go introduce
yourself to the other members of her
motley crew eg the giant blythe the
wolfman and selvius the pervert who by
the way has an entire other questline
where he tries to have you transform
ronnie into his own personal play doll
for use in his dungeon anyway after
introducing yourself to all the members
of team ronnie she explains to you that
she sent blythe into the eternal city of
nochron deep beneath the surface in
order to find a hidden treasure the next
step in her quest to overturn the golden
order and that you should go meet up
with blythe and help him out however
when you meet blithe he's stumped and
has absolutely no idea how to actually
get into nocron after a little bit of
chatting he asks you to ask selvius who
asks you to ask selen about what to do
next and when you ask selen she reveals
to you that the reason you can't find
your way forward is probably because
general radon is blocking the fate of
the carrier royal family from moving
forward but let me explain what that
means basically at some point most
likely in between godwin's murder and
the shattering war but possibly way
before maybe even leading to ronnie's
plan being executed in the first place
we don't know for sure general radon the
son of rinalda who was loyal to his
father and the golden order instead of
his mother and the carrier royal family
took it upon himself to personally use
his gravity magic and freeze the stars
in place which according to selen were
the carriers of the fate of the carrion
royal family she says that if radon were
to die then it's possible that the stars
would once again move and resume opening
fate's door for ronnie so that's exactly
what you and blyth do next you head down
south east to red main castle and
challenge in after about 25 tries defeat
general radon and right after his defeat
just like selen said his power wanes and
the stars resume their movement and an
asteroid crashes to the earth opening
the way properly to the city of nocron
and let me just pause for a second to
say that general radon is an absolute
badass okay moving on you venture
through this new opening in the earth
into the city of nochron and eventually
come across the treasure that ronnie
needs the finger slayer blade which is a
blade capable of killing the two fingers
and harming the greater will that the
people of nochron created long ago you
return to ronnie's rise and give the
blade to ronnie who admits that she's
surprised you were the one to retrieve
it and not blythe she offers you a
strange statue as a reward says hi to
torrent then says she's gotta leave and
do something alone and says goodbye once
again at this point though some astute
players might notice that her shadow
blithe is nowhere to be found and this
is where things get kind of sad if you
talk to eg before going into nochron he
says that you should go on without
blythe because blythe was given another
important mission from ronnie apparently
however ronnie's reaction about you
getting the blade before blythe proves
that she didn't tell blithe to do
anything else eg the giant was lying to
you see if you venture to the forlorn
evergal you can hear howling and upon
approaching the magical prison you find
out that blythe himself is trapped
inside and he was trapped in there by
none other than eg the giant who told
bly that he would bring bail to lady
rani which is an old english word that
means destructive evil blythe is
saddened and confused by this and claims
that he is a part of his sister ronnie's
being her shadow and that there was no
chance that something like that would
ever happen you have the option to
either let him free or keep him
imprisoned but whatever you choose if
you go to egy and report that you found
blythe he will say that blythe was given
to ronnie by the two fingers and
therefore harbors a dark secret which is
that if an empirian were to refuse the
will of the two fingers that imperian's
shadow would go mad and become a
horrible curse upon the emperian he says
that it doesn't matter what blithe
thinks because this is something that is
pre-programmed into his very being to do
should ronnie ever resist the greater
will and says that blythe needs to be
neutralized but we're gonna pause on
blythe's story and resume ronnie's since
they take place separately from this
point forward meantime ronnie did indeed
leave to embark on the next part of her
quest and to follow after her you'll
have to go through a portal in rena's
rise where you will find her hilariously
disguised as a smaller doll after trying
to speak with her multiple times at the
nearby grace she finally opens up and
tells you that you need to eliminate the
baleful shadows which prowl the lands
the baleful shadows are assassins that
the two fingers sent to kill ronnie
since she is now not only resisting
their plan but is an active threat to it
it's here that you're given some extra
dialogue with ronnie as you progress
towards the baleful shadow assassin and
she reveals to you the famous quotes
that many people reference about she
millennia and mikala being imperials and
that she thinks blythe and eg and now
even you are willing to give too much to
her progress until you encounter the
shadow and you will find out that it
shockingly resembles blithe when you
approach she will talk to it directly
telling it to tell the two fingers that
ronnie the witch is coming to rend their
flesh after killing the last shadow
assassin she thanks you calls you her
dear and asks you to tell blithe and eg
that she loves them as she leaves she
gives you the discarded palace key which
says it opens a treasure chest passed
down to carry in princesses that is
found near rinalda once you go to ranala
and open up the chest located behind her
inside you find the darkmoon ring which
states that its purpose is to be given
by lunar princess ronnie to her consort
hint hint long story short you chase
after ronnie and eventually find her
located beneath the cathedral of mauna
seelys where she sits without her robes
or hat on in front of her own two
fingers who she personally killed at
long last with the finger slayer blade
that you found for her from nocron she's
sitting there motionless though so you
place the ring on her finger and she
disappears then reappears as her normal
self and tells you that she's glad
you're her consort before disappearing
again and saying that you will meet
again after you travel the path of the
lord aka after you complete the game at
this point if you travel back to
ronnie's rise you can finally stumble
across blythe who is now hostile
crouching over a dead body and mumbling
to himself if you listen into what he's
saying before engaging in combat you can
actually hear him saying no i'm part of
her very being i could never betray her
no matter what might happen ronnie she
needs me and then confused and
disoriented you have to put him down
because he couldn't resist what he was
destined to become the body that he's
crouching over before your fight is a
black knife assassin and as a reminder
the black knife assassins are in service
to ronnie who was most likely sent to
try to stop blythe once eg learned that
he broke out of his cell if you talk to
eg again he says that he will catch up
with blythe soon enough and when he does
he only hopes that the poor shadow will
accept his apology you can speak to
ronnie again by resting at the new grey
spot that appears at the top of her
tower where she will explain to you
exactly what it is she plans to do with
the world once she has her way she says
that her order will not be of gold but
will be of the stars and moon of the
chill night and that life and souls and
order will be unbound and that the
certainties of sight emotion faith and
touch will become impossibilities she
asks once again if you will still become
her lord and at the end of the game you
have the option once you've defeated
ratigan and the elden beast you can
choose to summon ronnie before the elden
ring instead of mending it yourself
doing so will successfully end her quest
line and bring on the age of the stars
which entails ronnie allowing grace the
greater will the elden ring and the erd
tree all together to fade away into
nothingness you then become her one and
only consort and lord alongside her and
the two of you live happily ever after
the end for now if you're interested in
a deep dive explaining ronnie's ending
in detail then remember my buddy monster
maze you might want to check his channel
out because that's exactly what he's
about to cover
wow this video became really really long
but i felt that everything i covered was
necessary for understanding the full
picture of ronnie the witch and i hope
you enjoyed thank you so much for
watching and if you're still watching
please consider leaving a like on this
video since that really helps out with
the algorithm and subscribe to stick
around for all the other lore dives we
have yet to delve into on the channel
and let me know in the comments below
who you would like for me to cover next
if you missed the previous video about
merica and radigan i'll have it linked
in the description below as always huge
thanks to my bandit crew and a warm
welcome to the new members of crispy tea
plays and ashley h who recently joined
up right here on youtube that's all i've
got for this one so as always i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day this
is bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out
[Music]
you